nos dan una serie y nos preguntan qué
serie deberíamos usar en el criterio de
comparación del límite déjame subrayó
esa parte criterio de comparación del
límite para determinar si la serie
converge y aquí vamos a empezar
recordando qué es lo que nos dice el
criterio de comparación del límite así
es que vamos a empezar recordando el
criterio de comparación del límite el
cual nos dice que si tenemos dos series
y voy a usar esta anotación esta es una
serie esta es la otra serie estas son
las dos series y además sabemos que
todas las a n y las b n son mayores o
iguales a 0 y esto sucede para todas las
en es
ya que sabemos todo esto acerca de estas
dos series lo que nos dice el criterio
de comparación del límite es que si él
límite cuando n tiende a infinito de a n
/ b n es igual a c donde por cierto se
es positivo eso lo que significa es que
0 es menor que se dice es menor que
infinito si sucede esto entonces
entonces ambas series convergen ambas
series convergen
ambas series divergen
ambas series divergen y esto tiene
bastante sentido porque si tenemos estas
dos series y estamos diciendo por aquí
que conforme tomamos valores de n más
grandes conforme nos alejamos y tomamos
términos de esta serie cada vez más
lejanos
si esos términos se parecen cada vez más
entonces tiene sentido que ambas series
convergen o ambas series divergen y esto
lo vemos muy bien en un vídeo anterior
acerca del criterio de la comparación
del límite pero bueno si por aquí
decimos que esta es la a sub n entonces
cuál de estas series podemos utilizar
para determinar si esta serie converge o
no bueno pues vamos a ver esta serie no
se ve acotada está por acá no se ve tan
parecida es cierto tiene el mismo
denominador tiene tres a la n 1 pero el
numerador no se comporta de la misma
forma
ahora está por acá se ve bastante
interesante porque esta la podemos
escribir como la suma desde que n es
igual a 1 hasta infinito de 2 a la n
entre 3 a la n esta es una serie muy
parecida a ésta y estas series son muy
parecidas la única diferencia es que en
esta en el denominador tenemos este
menos 1 y aquí en este denominador no
tenemos ese menos 1 entonces tiene
sentido pensar que estas dos series se
comportan de la misma forma sobre todo
porque esta es una constante entonces
vamos a ver si si en serio se comportan
de la misma forma lo que necesitamos es
encontrar el
límite cuando n tiende a infinito
y por cierto sabemos que tanto esta
serie como esta serie sus términos son
mayores que 0 tanto para uno como para
dos tres y todos los valores que puede
tomar en este término es mayor que cero
y lo mismo sucede con esta serie para
todos los valores que puede tomar n este
término es mayor que cero
así es que estas dos series si cumplen
con las condiciones iniciales y ahora sí
vamos a ver si se cumple que este límite
sea igual a un valor que sea mayor que
cero y menor que infinito entonces vamos
a colocar por aquí el término a n que es
este 2 a la n entre 3 a la n 1 y lo
dividimos entre el término b n
2 a la n entre 3 a la n iv para resolver
este límite primero vamos a hacer una
manipulación algebraica por acá esto es
2 a la n entre 3 a la n 1
3 a la n entre 2 a la n dividimos el
numerador y el denominador entre 2 a la
n iv lo que nos queda es 3 a la n entre
3 a la n 1 podemos dividir el numerador
y el denominador entre 3 a la n iv nos
queda 1 entre 1 - 1 entre 3 a la n por
lo que este límite es igual al límite
cuando n tiende a infinito de 1 entre 1
- 1 entre 3 a la n iv este límite a que
es igual
bueno pues cuando n tiende a infinito
este término de aquí se va a 0 por lo
que este límite cuando n tiende a
infinito es igual a 1 y 1
definitivamente es mayor que 0 y menor
que infinito por lo que el criterio de
comparación del límite nos dice que el
destino de estas dos series
está ligado a ambas convergen o ambas
divergen así es que esta es una serie
con la que podemos utilizar el criterio
de comparación del límite con esta otra
serie y ahora pensemos en si ambas
series convergen o divergen a ver
analicemos esta serie converge o diverge
bueno pues es una serie geométrica cuya
razón dos tercios es menor que 1
entonces esta serie definitivamente
converge y como esta serie converge el
criterio de comparación del límite nos
dice que nuestra serie original también
converge así es que ese converge
converge
y listo terminamos